290 4 millones de euros
2494 millones la suerte fue echada y
ahora los Afortunados lo celebran en
muchos municipios de España los
ganadores de la lotería de Navidad
festejan su fortuna
muy muy muy especial es una alegría y no
puedo deciros nada más porque llevo me
voy a echar a llorar el premio mayor
conocido como el gordo quedó en manos de
muchos ciudadanos en varias regiones del
país el mismo número el
5.490 se vendió varias veces el bote
total alcanzó este año los 2520 millones
de euros un poco más que los 2.410
millones del año pasado la Euforia
también está presente entre los
vendedores celebran que el dinero se
quede entre sus comunidades
impresionante hemos repartido cinco
grandes premios el gordo de Navidad ha
vuelto a caer aquí en manizales estamos
súper contentos al final ha sido el
gordo el cuarto premio y 305 premios en
total estamos ya os digo contentísimos
a una excepción verano que viene gente
de fuera pero si todo gente de clientes
habituales
algún proveedor lo típico toda gente
conocida vamos y trabajadora claro los
Afortunados que pagaron por los boletos
20 euros serán recompensados con un pago
de 400.000 euros
325.000 tras el pago de impuestos por
cada papeleta que posean
son los alumnos del colegio de San
Ildefonso los encargados año tras año de
cantar los números ganadores y los
premios a todo el país
la lotería de Navidad inició en 1812
esta tradición yacentenaria marca el
inicio de la temporada navideña en el
país